the magic continues in fact we've got a
very fun surprise as well
a guest over there
but this time do
pay attention to the man behind the
carton one of our vffs
can you guess who oz is that's right
whoever can will win a thousand dollars
oz will you reveal yourself to us later
in the show
go away i'm going to give you to the
count of 10
to get your ugly yellow no good keister
off my property before i
pump your guts full of lead one two
okay okay we hear you okay
geez all right well hopefully that was a
clue
okay we'll check back in later with you
oz let's check in with the great and
powerful oz can you give us a little
bitty baby
clue someone gets to win money who
really are you
i am the great and powerful oz i
fear nothing fine i fear two things
these things and aftershave but that's
it just those two
who do you think it is well i guess
we'll find out soon
very soon we will find out who is behind
the curtain
our own personal wizard of oz oz are you
ready to show yourself
do not arouse the wrath of the great and
powerful oz
no one scares me except that old man
with a snow shovel who lives down the
street
he gives me the heebies now be gone huh
very mysterious who could it be i don't
know but i do love a surprise i'm not
gonna lie
we're celebrating the wizard of oz and
we have a great and powerful and secret
oz
we're about to reveal we've been giving
you clues throughout the show about the
identity of our mysterious
oz and one vff is going to win
1 000 if they can guess who it is let's
get our vf up
up here tracy
oh how fun if you were living in a
musical land like the trolls
what music genre would you live in rock
perfect i love rock who doesn't it's a
classic
okay i have one final clue for you
before you guess
ready okay okay he's the wizard of
oz
macaulay
[Applause]
mccully culkin so happy to see you
i'm happy to be here i'm happy to see
you as well
you look like a beautiful witch i got
all dressed up for you thank you tracy
great job
and i can't wait to hear what you spend
the money on